you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am on Leech SOR
and I am going to play a 4-2 game trying
something a little bit different here I
don't know who I'm playing against just
the time control okay that seems a
little bit odd
okay I'm just gonna take so I'm not
going to know who I'm playing against
until the game is over I am currently in
Zen mode
so just the clock just the position to
focus on
the bishop
huh
I mean I'm gonna say let's uh let's get
c5 in immediately okay well this must
not be the most testing line I do have
some idea of the opponent I'm up against
I did seek for 2,000 plus anywhere from
2,000 to 2,900 the the top there so I
don't think I have any problems out of
the opening I'm questioning for a moment
if I couldn't do without castling
I'm going to say no it's still a little
bit too complicated still too many
pieces on board all right what do I want
to do with
you know white is working with the
majority just b6 Bishop d7
I'll say b6 Bishop b7
probably end up putting a rook on d8 and
maybe I inch my king over to you seven
we'll see
I'm thinking maybe white is hinting at
an expansion I'm gonna kind of put a
halt to that I don't want to allow white
to expand so freely and and in fact let
me go one more step I think this was the
night's only only good square okay you
go to see four but maybe there's some
annoying pin
to pay these guys advancing some
sure where I want to go with my night
just yeah one of these two
okay still going still going with b4 so
apparently okay with split pawn
structure huh
all right
maybe Bishop to e3 I'm gonna go with
Bishop a3 and now I have a little bit
more of an idea
I'm anticipating some pressure on b6 so
I want to connect nights maybe here with
tempo yeah this is a week square so
okay if I go there now
well maybe I should just get the bishops
off yeah
feel that I'm really promoting a rook by
allowing this recapture so
I'm actually considering rook a3 right
now
No where would I like to have my night
see
three I think night here to here is a
little bit annoying
ah no actually
I could I could still go there let's see
a night here drops oh no it doesn't
quite drop upon because of Bishop takes
pawn but they're okay suppose I do this
kind of put up a little bit of a fight
over the b5 square my rook is kind of
short on squares
night here okay I could go there bishops
gonna have to move first and there's an
a great square for the bishop that I see
so I'd like to gather these moves in
maybe King f8 King e7 still
I'll see
arie or even or even this though I'm not
not threatening
yeah let's still start with this I'm not
threatening the phone right now but I'm
doing this more so to cover c6
so my next move King FA will then be
threatening takes
so all queenside phones are weak
think I'm better in this position I
think these targets
are more accessible
I could consider this move
[Music]
get my knight in the ball game this
square is opened up but I do have this
as a reply okay welcoming a light square
bishop exchange I think I'm certainly a
fan of this move because I demote one of
whites pieces and let me kind of take
away I think what is a best square for
white
some multiple white pieces that can make
use of d4 but not now
and I'm going to say let's kind of grab
some space on the kingside I'm tempted
to still go for this but I want to kind
of fight some against their potential
advance on the kingside trying to maybe
dislodge my knight
at any point I could come over here and
basically restrict another piece
go here a lot of
I think even in an endgame I'm better
major excuse me a major piece Pacific
physician you know I go here right
I close to winning upon actually I think
I am I was tempted to go for a night
trade that night is not so great
hmm now I think I am gonna go on for
this is considering this move night here
but I don't I don't have this move the
Knights defending I have that
but then the king could step up
we'll see I think it's intolerable you
have to just get rid of em take here it
may end up that it's a four versus three
that I've tried to convert but not here
actually um I'm gonna grab in what way
I'll take with this guy keep pressure
here so I could win upon let's start
with this check I like to keep two rooks
on it if I can
okay you know what I want this move and
then I think it's forced that the rook
has to play here 42 seconds
I'm gonna say that this is best I think
it's kind of crazy if this pawn bolts
the these these rooks will gobble up
these two and I'll be able to get behind
yes
so here and I believe taking hears is
best I'm up on and soon to be a second
one and I will be in time to have my
rook ideally placed behind this guy
from here I may it may be the case I do
not need my Kings help let's take a step
with the pawn
yeah the king definitely has to come
over can I can I work without making I
feel that I can I'll take another step
and I think I could just keep pushing
I'll go another one the King has to go
here now and you know I'm soon gonna be
threatening mate mates right next
there's no fancy you know rook move even
if this pawn wasn't here the King sits
well and these two we might have a
resigner find out okay they're just gone
the King in the corner there really
wasn't anything good okay so there's the
opponent Tori
1971 on throw a gg
not sure what that's saying I'll have to
look it up
hopefully hopefully uh nothing bad okay
so let's have a look at this one
what - no I will yeah maybe maybe I'll
just dive right into the analysis I've
had this before and I think I've played
it where I didn't immediately follow up
with c5 but I think c5 is the way to go
though III guess I could also consider
a5 because there isn't this natural
development and development of the King
Knight to f3 any more controlling e5
yeah I think right here it's already
equal
I thought maybe better is for white to
develop maybe Bishop here
yeah maybe Bishop to e3 is a little bit
better but I think is equal right about
this point move seven eight
and then I think I spoke a lot about the
majority this is probably off to
voluntarily split up the the pawn
structure like this maybe maybe it was
better for white to insert a four and
then think about you know sinking a
night into the b5 square or maybe even
Bishop here not sure but those are just
some rough thoughts I think I'm I'm
close to better here having a these
targets are more accessible to the black
pieces then this this pawn is this
target is for team wine
alright let's dive into the analysis
maybe I should have done this first
request a computer analysis so let's see
how it's looking
while it's crunching the numbers here
okay this does have a name selector
variation Bishop d3 is a considered best
to just chop new native six and it does
like c5 straight away 92 okay so
something there to support d4 after this
capture yeah I think we can safely call
it an even position there's there's no
no advantage for white out of the
opening
and no b6 just wants to develop a night
I guess b6 is okay as well hmm
c3 so apparently it's okay to allow b4
with tempo yeah I don't know I wasn't a
fan of of that and it's suggesting a
four
if I did play knight c6 here b4 what's
the idea I back up and then kind of try
to put a dent in this structure so let's
just make a passing moves the idea a 5
it's not suggesting a 5 but I imagine a
5 is a move maybe trying to grant my
pieces access to the c5 square might
have to under develop
but I have a good Square to work with
okay
I just stopped be four altogether
a four is a move a four-night bd7 ya saw
something else here because I'm gonna
have targets now after before suggesting
a three rookie one hmm okay
what's the what's the graph looking like
that's the graph inaccuracies mistakes
blunders for each
okay you know I'm I was definitely a fan
of this position once the dark square
bishop s' were off and I had this nice a
three square and it doesn't seem to
really be going down any the graph just
a little bit better as the moves go
along for black yeah I just want to see
the decision at the end here with my
when it's just the rooks
he five it's not calling for a g5
instead okay I guess there's many
approaches at this stage does it want to
go h5 no yeah rook C to a a now I want
to go with h6 still tiny advantage even
though material is bounced announced
it's getting pretty serious
Brooksie to a a what's the story with
this suppose oh I take the knight right
so there isn't a great way to defend a
to right I should have realized this I
could go right in for that a to pawn at
this stage
even at this moment right
story Rexy - I take the night okay
h5i takes e4 and I thought for a moment
about night here is this okay as well
yeah this is fine as well
also with an eye on the clock right
around this stage I want to kind of keep
it simple
and I think the best case scenario for
white is to try and enter a four versus
three and hold that
was able to gobble up a lot of pawns
so right now I I want to avoid that this
is what I wanted to check out I think
taking here and then
of course I'm still trying for something
but not easily converted No
just maybe doesn't like that for
starters what is it suggesting rook b5
oh yeah rook b5 and then here and then
the rook returns
maybe not because if rook here I have
the Brook here that's right
testing the rook b3 are preparing to me
this with that yeah it's going to be
tough to convert this
saying
Vantage four for black I won't want to
avoid this scenario if at all possible
for versus three and rookie three is is
the way forward keep two Brooks on
I have no fear of the white rooks
doubling on my second rank so
if I get here it's gonna be big trouble
so a for Ricky - II - this is far too
slow checks and meet threats made
threats and I can always scoop up the
rook like this and get behind the pawn
necessary
but
didn't have exactly that
mouths so even if I'm taking here okay
this is still excellent because of Roque
for the timing is just right for me to
grab a second pun
but taking here is good as well I think
clearest and then the King is not
necessary for this ending no good
solution at this stage just a lot of the
main one
okay well it's been a while for a blitz
game and first time for Zen mode
let me know what you think of that idea
may be doing a Zen mode from time to
time I think it's a pretty neat just
remove all distractions and just focus
on the game and the clock
okay anyhow feel free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two way
that's all for now
take care
you